ANN KIRSCHNER: Thank you.
Good afternoon.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I'm here to talk about "Lady at
the O.K. Corral." And it's
wonderful to talk to the Google
audience, since who
could write a book today
without Google?
And I was here with my first
book, "Sala's Gift."
I was first intrigued by the
story of Josephine Marcus Earp
when I learned that she'd been
a Jewish woman in Tombstone.
A Jewish woman in Tombstone sort
of sounds like a joke you
might read on "The Onion." And
I thought about how much I
thought I knew about the Old
West, which turned out to be
mostly untrue.
And so this became for me a
journey into the untold story
of the Old West.
Like a lot of people who grew
up in the '50s, it was all
about watching Wyatt
Earp on television.
That's actually a picture
of me as a baby.
And the things that I thought
I didn't know began to
overwhelm the things
that I did know.
For instance, where were
the women of the West?
When you read the early stories
about Tombstone and
the frontier, it was is if there
were no wives, mothers,
women, daughters of any kind.
Because all you read
about was the men.
And yet, I was finding out
that there was a woman in
Tombstone, a Jewish woman
in Tombstone,
named Josephine Marcus.
So that was enormously
intriguing to me.
Then there was the idea of the
gunfight at the O.K. Corral.
So I have a Google Alert
on O.K. Corral.
And every single day, there is
something in the news that
evokes the idea of
the O.K. Corral.
It may be something totally
unrelated, something like a
congressional showdown,
or an NBA game, or a
teachers' union fight.
I remember seeing that one.
But every single day,
there's something.
It is sunk so deeply into the
American psyche as the idea of
confrontation.
And yet, here was this woman,
this gutsy, busty broad, who
had a lover on both sides
of the O.K. Corral.
So instead of the story of
politics and power that I
thought the O.K. Corral was all
about, it was also a tale
of jealousy and revenge.
And then there's the story
of Wyatt Earp himself.
We think of him as the law man,
wearing the white hat.
Well, it turns out that the
story that we know was really
shaped by Josephine Marcus
Earp, his wife.
This was a way for a good, clean
story to be told about
Wyatt, and Josephine was really
a master of celebrity
and image shaping.
But let me take you back
to the beginning
of Josephine's life.
What she told everybody was that
she was the daughter of a
wealthy German merchant.
None of that was true.
Her family was not wealthy,
and they were not German.
They were actually
from Prussia,
or what is now Poland.
And that's a very important
distinction, as it turns out.
So her family came to the United
States around 1850.
Josephine was born in 1860.
They lived in New York.
She lived in New York during
the Civil War.
And then her family was
not doing pretty well
economically.
Her dad was struggling to
make it as a baker.
And everywhere in the New York
press, you would read about
San Francisco, and all the
wonderful things that were
happening in San Francisco.
And that was even before
Silicon Valley.
So Josephine's family picked up
again, and left New York,
and went out to San Francisco.
And they would've arrive by
steamer through the Isthmus of
Panama, which had opened
fairly recently.
The community that they arrived
in was a thriving
Jewish community, but it was a
highly stratified community.
There were the German Jews,
who tended to be the more
affluent, educated, politically
involved Jews.
And then there was
everybody else.
And the Polish Jews were
at the bottom of
the everybody else.
So Josephine grew up in a San
Francisco where her family was
on the wrong side
of the tracks.
And Josephine was not a young
woman who wanted to be on the
wrong side of anything.
So she ran away from home.
She was about 18 years old,
and the Pinafore craze was
sweeping America, to an
extent that you cannot
even imagine now.
But every town seemed to have
a Pinafore company.
Josephine wasn't much of a
singer, but she was kind of a
good dancer, and felt that she
could act her way through a
part on the Pinafore.
And so she joined a touring
company that was going to the
Arizona territory.
She joined the Pauline Markham
touring company.
And there's Ms. Markham lying
out on the couch there.
And she danced the sailors
hornpipe, and was pretty
competent at it.
But the important thing was
that while she was on tour
with the company, she caught the
eye of the man who would
soon become the first sheriff
of Cochise County.
No, not Wyatt Earp.
Johnny Behan.
So she comes to--
Ooh, you know what, let
me cover her up.
And before I even get you to
Tombstone, let me tell you a
little bit about what Josephine
looked like.
She was small.
She was very curvy.
And we don't really know
anything about authenticated
pictures of her as a young
woman, because she either
destroyed them or they were
lost, possibly in the 1906 San
Francisco earthquake.
And most of the pictures
that you find online
today are not her.
But I've done an extensive
amount of analysis with a
forensic artist who's a
professor at John Jay College
at the City University of New
York to take the authenticated
photographs that we have of
Josephine, which are mostly of
her in later life, and to do a
regression analysis to figure
out which of the photos that
had been put forth about
Josephine really might be her.
So if you look at these
photographs here, the ones
along the top are ones that I
have some reason to believe
are Josephine, and have
been examined by
the forensic analyst.
And the ones at the bottom
really are Josephine.
And I've done an interview with
the artist, which you see
up at LadyattheOKCorral.com.
I would give anything for a
picture that I was absolutely
certain was Josephine.
But in the meantime, we
settle for these.
OK, back to Tombstone.
So in 1879, Wyatt Earp and his
brothers arrive in Tombstone.
They all have wives,
common-law wives.
And Wyatt is with Mattie
Blaylock, the woman here over
on the left.
And that's Wyatt
in the middle.
An incredibly handsome man
of uncommon charisma.
Really quite striking.
And as you'll see, he retains
those characteristics even as
an older man.
The fellow on the right is
Johnny Behan, the first
sheriff of Cochise County.
So the people on either side of
Wyatt, those are the people
that Josephine most didn't
want you to know about.
Because for the rest of her
life, what she would be trying
to hide would be, first of
all, that she came to
Tombstone to be the common-law
wife of Johnny Behan.
And second of all, that Wyatt
already had a wife in
Tombstone, and that was
Mattie Blaylock.
I said she came to Tombstone
to be the common-law wife.
That's not really true.
She came to Tombstone to
marry Johnny Behan.
But when she got there, the
situation was very different.
It turns out that Johnny
had been married.
He was now divorced.
But he had a nine-year-old son,
and he expected Josephine
to take care of his
nine-year-old son.
That was fine.
Josephine and Albert became
very good friends, and
remained close for the
rest of her life.
But she didn't count on
Johnny's total lack of
interest in actually
getting married.
Nor did she count on the fact
that Johnny was a womanizer.
So once she gets there, she
discovers that Johnny is not
the man she expected to be.
She leaves him.
And that's when she meets Wyatt
Earp, who's now the
Deputy U.S. Marshal
of Tombstone.
The gunfight at the
O.K. Corral.
If you want to be a real
insider, you should probably
raise your hand immediately
and say "but, but, but it
didn't really take place at
the O.K. Corral, did it?!
And the truth is,
no, it didn't.
It took place on
Fremont Street,
outside of the O.K. Corral.
But certainly in common
parlance, we think of it as
the O.K. Corral.
Josephine was in Tombstone.
She heard the shots.
She runs to the site of where
the O.K. Corral was, sees that
Wyatt, of all the people
involved in the
shootout, is unscathed.
And she leaves.
The events afterwards involved
Wyatt's brother being murdered
and his other brother being
severely injured.
It's clear at this point that
there's no time anymore for
romance or love in Tombstone.
Wyatt sends his common-law wife,
Mattie Blaylock, off to
his parents.
I actually think this was the
most cowardly act that Wyatt
Earp ever did.
He sends Mattie Blaylock off
to his parents with the
expectation that he
will come for her.
She could have waited for the
rest of her life, because he
never was going to
come for her.
Josephine realizes that it's
time for her to get out of
Tombstone as well, and
she goes back to her
long-suffering immigrant parents
in San Francisco.
And she, too, is waiting
for Wyatt.
Only Wyatt really does
come for Josephine.
So this couple that met in
this tumultuous time in
Tombstone--
which was then the largest city
in Arizona, a bustling
silver mining town--
they end up spending the
next 47 years together.
And it is a tale of remarkable
love of adventure.
They were fortune seeking, but
they never really cared that
much about money.
It was great when they
had it, and they made
do when they didn't.
But the nonstop love
of adventure is
what always gets me.
These were two people who
never really grew up.
The greatest adventure that they
had-- or at least the one
that I think I'm fondest of--
is when they went to Alaska
for the gold rush.
So when we think about the
Alaska gold rush, we think
about what it takes
to mine for gold.
All of that was very
labor intensive.
You needed a lot of equipment.
Until 1899.
And in 1899, gold was discovered
in Nome, Alaska.
And it was not only that there
was gold in Nome, Alaska, but
it was on the public beach, on
the shore of the Bering Sea.
You could go right out there
with a little pan, as you see
me there on the Bering Sea, and
just shuffle it around,
and gold would appear.
Imagine.
So you can see the crowds that
are massing, in the picture on
the upper left, on the
waterfront in Seattle.
By the summer of 1900, when the
news swept America that
you could pan for gold right
on the surface of the sea,
there were just tens of
thousands of people who were
trying to get to Nome--
which, the summer before, had
a population of about 50.
There were no hotels,
there was nothing.
There was just these white tents
that you see in this
fuzzy picture on the
bottom left.
Wyatt and Josephine made
a fortune there.
It was a very difficult time for
Josephine, because she was
so far away from her family.
She was still very close
to her relatives.
But she stuck it out in Nome.
She stuck it out in all the
places that they went to.
And when they left Nome, they
really had enough money to
live comfortably for the
rest of their life,
if they were careful.
This was not a careful couple.
Money tended to slip through
their fingers, probably the
way that those gold flecks went
through your fingers in
the Bering Sea.
They spent most of the rest of
their life going in a circuit
between Los Angeles and San
Francisco, Oakland where her
family lived, and to the desert
right between Arizona
and California.
And this is a picture of them
in their desert camp.
You can see Wyatt
there is feeding
their little dog, Earpie.
And Josephine, who's gotten
a little portly, is
looking over them.
Josephine was a woman
who loved luxury.
She loved fancy hotels,
she loved clean
sheets and good food.
But she also loved
the outdoors.
She also loved living
out in the desert.
And so there were these two
sides to her character.
Similarly, when we think about
my title, "Lady at the O.K.
Corral," Josephine's feeling
about being a lady also was
filled with conflict.
On the one hand, she wanted
to be respectable,
as her sister was.
Her sister had become a
successful businesswomen and
pillar of society in Oakland,
San Francisco.
And Josephine admired
her sister a lot.
But there was a part of
Josephine that was remarkably
rebellious, and always searching
for adventure.
So when you think of or a living
out and then in the
desert with Wyatt and their dog,
it was that adventuresome
side that was uppermost.
As the years go by, Tombstone
is actually never far from
public consciousness.
And in 1929, the first
Helldorado days were held in
Tombstone--
which, at this point all
the mines were gone.
It was really just
a tourist town.
But the most important thing
that happened, from Wyatt and
Josephine's point of view, was
that Hollywood had just come
to Los Angeles.
And a lot of the early movies
were actually Westerns.
And the two heroes you see here,
William S. Hart and Tom
Mix, were amongst the most
popular early cowboys.
And they were both very, very
close friends of Wyatt's.
And as stories began to appear,
Josephine's ability to
manage Wyatt's public relations
began to be her
driving compulsion.
Wyatt was famous in his own
lifetime, but there was always
controversy about
the O.K. Corral.
Who had shot first?
Was Wyatt a hero or, as I've
heard him described, a
homicidal maniac?
So this controversy
was always raging.
Josephine attempted to squash
bad stories if she knew they
were going to occur.
If they already had come out,
then she would mount a public
relations campaign.
Again, very modern.
She would reach out to Wyatt's
famous friends, the cowboys,
or people like Tasker Oddie,
the senator and governor of
Nevada, who was a big fan of
Wyatt's, and get them to write
stories on Wyatt's behalf.
And then if all else failed,
she would try and get a
retraction.
Wyatt had been friends in his
youth with the father of
William Randolph Hearst.
And so Josephine would do things
like call up William
Randolph Hearst and say, Mr.
Hearst, there's this terrible
article in the Los
Angeles paper.
You must kill it.
And if it could be killed,
get me a retraction.
And she would.
She would occasionally
get a retraction.
But that wasn't good enough.
What they really needed was
to tell their own story.
And so when an enterprising
writer and press agent named
Stuart Lake approached Josephine
and Wyatt with the
idea of writing a biography,
Josephine thought, well, this
is the way actually to
get our story out.
We will shape the story.
And he sat with Wyatt
many, many times
throughout 1928 and '29.
And as it turns out, these
were the last months of
Wyatt's life.
Until the day he died, he
remained that incredibly
handsome, tall, strapping, six
foot two fellow that first
came in to Tombstone.
Josephine, alas--
this is really not fair--
but she didn't age as
well as Wyatt did.
And that's a picture of
her in later life.
Wyatt died in January 1929.
The scene from the pall
bearers at his funeral
included Tom Mix and William
S. Hart, as well as
playwrights like
William Eisner.
And really began to take shape
in a national news story about
the death of the West, the death
of the Old Frontier,
with Wyatt Earp as its
most famous symbol.
Josephine wrote to Stuart Lake
and asked him to come to the
funeral, which he did.
And then, in the year following
Wyatt's death,
finally that book
was published.
And although it's now the height
of the Depression, it
was an immediate best seller.
And to my knowledge,
has actually
never gone out of print.
So Josephine is left alone, no
real means of support, except
that she does share in the
royalties from the book.
And in 1932, 1933, Lincoln
Ellsworth, the famous Arctic
explorer, approaches Josephine
to say that he's going back to
the South Pole, and he'd like
to go and somehow honor his
hero, Wyatt Earp.
And he comes up with the
idea of naming his
ship after Wyatt Earp.
Well, how does Josephine
feel about that?
Well, we already know, Josephine
is a PR master.
So she thinks this
is a great idea.
And she supplies Lincoln
Ellsworth with Wyatt's last
pair of eyeglasses,
and she gives him
one of Wyatt's shotguns.
And Lincoln Ellsworth creates a
little shrine in his cabin.
And off goes the ship.
And there's a photograph from
the L.A. Times of Josephine
and Lincoln Ellsworth.
But what's really interesting
here is that it's hard for us
to imagine today how the public
was obsessed with
Lincoln Ellsworth and this
trip to the Arctic.
Why it was in the
New York Times--
the name "Wyatt Earp," again,
following the Lincoln
Ellsworth ship--
at least once a month
for six years?
Because people were following
every step of Lincoln
Ellsworth's voyage.
And when Lincoln Ellsworth was
lost at sea, then it was a
front page story for
weeks on end.
If you look at the York Times
from January 22, 1936, here's
the day when Edward the Seventh
is proclaimed the new
leader of England.
And there, over on the left-hand
side of the page, on
the front page of the New York
Times, is good old Wyatt Earp,
because Lincoln Ellsworth
has been found.
He had been lost at sea.
Now he was found.
And again, Wyatt Earp is
back on the front page.
So in the mid '30s, after the
Stuart Lake biography, you get
this turbo charge of good
PR for Wyatt Earp.
Josephine, I think, was
emboldened by this to think
that, maybe now it was the
time to tell her story.
And of course, she's eager
for the money on top
of everything else.
She sees an article in the
L.A. Times about an Earp
relative who happens
to be a writer.
And she finds a family in
L.A., the Cason and the
Ackerman family, who
are Earp relatives.
And she begins to work with
these two wonderful women
about writing her biography.
And there she is over
on the left.
You can see, she's slimmed
down a little bit.
She kind of looks like
a Italian widow.
And there she's with
the Cason family.
They work intensively
together.
They even go back
to Tombstone.
They stop off at what has now
been renamed in honor of Wyatt
Earp, the town of Earp,
California.
There's Josephine with one
of her biographers.
She visits Tombstone for the
first time since 1882.
That must've been an
incredible journey.
And they write this
memoir together.
I'll take you back here.
Only the closer they get to the
truth, the closer they get
to finding out about Josephine's
relationship to
Johnny Behan and the story
of Mattie Blaylock.
Josephine to began to get really
nervous about this.
I told you that Mattie Blaylock
had gone back to
Wyatt's parents.
When Wyatt never did show up for
her, Mattie finally read
the tea leaves, and left
his parents' house.
She had no visible means of
support, very little education.
She became a prostitute, a drug
addict, and eventually
committed suicide, telling
anybody who would listen that
this had all happened
because she had been
deserted by Wyatt Earp.
That's the story that
Josephine didn't
want anyone to know.
And so the more digging the
Cason family was doing into
Josephine's past, the more
nervous she became.
Until she became so nervous that
she said, that's the end
of the biography.
We're not going to
do this memoir.
She forced them to burn the
manuscript, and she put a
curse on anyone who would
tell her story.
Which I confess, sometimes
makes me nervous.
But I figure there must
be a statute of
limitations on that.
After that happened,
Josephine's life
spiraled down herself.
She had very little money, and
she was increasingly paranoid,
and would go to visit some
of Wyatt's friends--
one in particular named
John Flood.
Sort of stalking him.
And he got nervous, and began to
record the things that she
would do, like the day that she
showed up at his door, put
her fist through the screen,
and said "I'll get back at
you, good and hard." And this is
from a manuscript page that
John Flood wrote, I guess
keeping track of Josephine's
activities.
But she didn't have too
much longer to live.
She died in 1944.
When Wyatt died, Josephine,
whose feeling about being
Jewish was pretty much, well,
it's a fact about me, but--
as Nora Ephron said-- not
necessarily the most important
fact about me.
She really had very little
relationship to any of the
Jewish communities that were
at the time in Tombstone or
Nome or any of those.
And yet, when it came time to
figure out where to bury Wyatt
Earp, she did turn back
to her religion.
And she buried him in the Jewish
cemetery outside of San
Francisco, where her parents
were buried.
When she died in 1944,
destitute, and her funeral
expenses were paid by Sidney
Grauman, as of Grauman's
Theater, and William S. Hart.
They had been friends of
Josephine's and Wyatt's.
Her funeral was officiated over
by a rabbi, and then she
was buried in the
same cemetery.
So the story of Josephine and
Wyatt, which stretches over
these 47 years, it took me to
a lot of different places.
I didn't actually go everywhere
on this map.
I think I missed El Paso.
But there was a tremendous
amount of research
that went into it.
And I thought you might want to
take a look at some of the
original letters that I used
to put the story together.
Any time you assemble a story
like this, it's kind of like a
giant jigsaw puzzle.
And Josephine's original
letters were very
much part of it.
By the way, one of the things
I discovered in working with
some young college students at
Macaulay Honors College is
that they didn't know how to
read cursive handwriting.
They kept wanting me to put it
through optical character
recognition, and it would
all come out great.
I said, now, now, it doesn't
quite work that way yet.
So we had a very interesting
time teaching 20-somethings
how to read Josephine's
handwriting.
Which I can read very well,
but that's because I'm a
little older.
There was also a tremendous
amount of work to be done.
The Cason family, I told you
they were ordered to burn that
manuscript by Josephine.
They didn't do it.
There was a copy that they
kept of the manuscript.
And that manuscript sits today
in Dodge City, where I spent
many happy days working on it.
Again, these are interesting
skills that are not
necessarily I'm going to be
around in the 22nd century.
But in the 21st century, the
ability to look at a
handwritten, hand-edited
manuscript
is still very important.
And I did work in many fine
libraries and archives.
It was really a wonderful
research project for me.
So that's the story of Josephine
Marcus Earp, the
untold story of Josephine
Marcus Earp.
To my mind, you can't tell the
story of American history
without the story of the Old
West and the frontier.
And you can't tell that story
without putting the women back
in the picture.
And when it comes to putting
women back in the picture, I
don't think you get much more
interesting than Josephine
Marcus Earp.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions for me?
You know, if you want to ask
me about the first time I
heard the word Google, I
could tell you that.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the photos.
ANN KIRSCHNER: Yes.
You say that you had
them verified.
What was that process like, and
why did you decide to go
through it?
ANN KIRSCHNER: The question was,
why did I feel that I had
to authenticate the photos
of Josephine Earp?
The world of what I call "Planet
Earp" is an extremely
contentious one.
I did my last book on
Holocaust history.
And I thought that was a
very complicated world.
And it certainly is.
But the contentiousness, the
quarrels, the feuds amongst
Earp historians--
and there are many amateur
are unlike anything
I have ever seen.
They are still fighting the
gunfight at the OK corral.
As a result, there's a great
deal of skepticism.
Well, you didn't really
find that.
That's really not true.
And so I knew that whatever I
did would be questioned and
questioned and questioned
again.
So I felt that I had to take
the pictures that--
If you go on Wikipedia--
until I change it--
the picture that's up there
now is absolutely not
Josephine Marcus Earp.
It makes no sense from
any analysis.
And yet, people have
put it forth.
It's like the tale of the
Loch Ness Monster.
If somebody's making money on
something, they have all the
reasons to keep that
legend up.
And so that's why I went to
such great lengths to
authenticate the photographs.
AUDIENCE: How many other women
did you find while you were
researching Josephine
Marcus Earp?
You said that there
were a lot.
Can you name or offer
any other stories
about who you found?
ANN KIRSCHNER: There
were a lot.
In the category of women of
the West and women in
Tombstone, there was some very
interesting characters.
Like Nellie Cachman, who is a
very successful entrepreneur
in Tombstone.
I thought she was absolutely
fascinating.
And I was also interested in the
story of women like Addie
Borland, who was the milliner
in town, who was the only
woman to testify at the inquest
after the gunfight at
the O.K. Corral.
But when you look at the
possible roles for women in
Tombstone, there really
weren't a
whole lot of choices.
There was one woman
who ran a school.
And there was one woman
who was there--
Actually, let me pause on her.
Probably, to me,
one of the most
interesting women in Tombstone.
She was a journalist.
And for some reason, right now
because you've asked me, I'm
blanking on her name.
But I'm going to come
up with in a second.
She was from San Diego.
And she wrote dispatches back
to the San Diego paper over
the course of a year and a
half, which included the
gunfight at the O.K. Corral.
And so many of the firsthand
impressions we have
come from her pen.
And she had a career afterwards
as a successful
journalist.
She was one of the examples
of professional women.
But there were many other women
who were there as wives
and family people.
John Clum, the mayor,
was married to a
very interesting woman.
And there were an awful
lot of prostitutes in
Tombstone as well.
The community that followed
the boom towns included
gamblers, saloon keepers,
and prostitutes.
And as the next boom
town emerged, they
would come to the fore.
So lots of interesting women.
The other category of women
that I've now gotten
interested in is the category
of the woman behind the man,
the women who shapes
the man's story.
I've told you that I
think this was a
burning passion for Josephine.
Think about Nancy Reagan.
How could you ever have a
biography of Ronald Reagan
that didn't talk about Nancy?
Or Libbie Custer, who spent most
of her life scrubbing out
the image of Custer, and making
sure that what he would
be remembered for is what
she thought he would
be remembered for.
By the way, Josephine's efforts
to keep the story of
Johnny Behan and Mattie Blaylock
away from us was
really entirely successful
in her own lifetime.
In 1955, the story of Mattie
Blaylock did emerge.
But it hasn't been
widely told.
It certainly hasn't overshadowed
the legend of
Wyatt Earp.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
there were Jewish communities
in Tombstone and Nome.
How large were those
communities?
ANN KIRSCHNER: They
were pretty large.
There was a Hebrew Benevolent
Association that had, I would
say, somewhere between 50
and 100 people who were
part of it in Tucson.
There were Jews who served on
the jury for the inquest
following the gunfight.
In Nome, Alaska, the story of
the first High Holy Days
services in September, 1900 was
a front page story in the
Nome newspapers.
Today, they call them the
"frozen chosen." and there are
large Jewish communities
throughout--
well, large is probably
an exaggeration.
There are sizable Jewish
communities throughout Alaska.
Part of the story of the
economic settling of Alaska
was the Alaska Commercial
Company, which was started in
San Francisco--
actually, originally started by
the Russian government, but
was then bought by
a group of Jewish
businessmen in San Francisco.
And was really the company store
in places like Nome Or
Rampart, Alaska, which
was another place
that the Earps were.
And I often think, particularly
in Tombstone,
when Josephine left Johnny Behan
and was not publicly
together with Wyatt, those
must have been very
dark days for her.
And yet, I never found any
evidence that she turned for
support or comfort to the
Jewish community.
And that distinction I made
between the German and the
Polish Jews, which was so
important in San Francisco,
was really meaningless
in the frontier.
No one really seemed to care
about that at all.
Clara Brown.
Clara Spalding Brown.
Memory's a funny thing.
But somewhere in that
last question, her
name came to my mind.
Thank you very much.